nachdem ich in der ersten Folge von
reisemonopoly in real life an der Küste
von Lagos in Portugal gelandet bin und
es für mich von dort aus mit einem
nachflug weiterging in die spanische
Mittelmeerstadt Valencia ich daraufhin
mit dem Boot auf die Baleareninsel
Formentera gereist bin und der ja auch
schon am Ende der letzten Folge gesehen
habt wo es heute hingeht du machst ein
Foto von irgendetwas in Loch Ness nein
seht ihr im heutigen Video meine
wirklich coole und spannende Reise zum
Loch Ness in Schottland ich bin echt
gespannt wohin es dann noch so für mich
geht aber jetzt erstmal viel Spaß mit
der vierten Folge von reisemonopoli in
real life und damit hey Leute was geht
ab herzlich willkommen zu einem Video es
geht endlich weiter ich befinde mich
gerade in Düsseldorf am Flughafen wenn
ihr hingefahren wir haben gerade 35
morgens ich muss jetzt schnell zum
Flughafen Security Check und dann geht's
erstmal nach London da habe ich einen
Aufenthalt von boah ich glaube fünf
Stunden und von London geht's dann
weiter zu Loch Ness man merkt auf jeden
Fall noch es ist Ferienzeit hier ist
alles komplett voll ich bin jetzt
wirklich am teuersten Parkhaus ganz nach
oben gefahren aber was anderes
habt wie man in Düsseldorf am Flughafen
günstig parken kann schreibt doch gerne
in die Kommentare so auf geht's
in Deutschland ne wirklich
kaputt jeder super los heute morgen also
das Wetter in Deutschland kann man
wirklich aktuell komplett vergessen
wobei wir fliegen halt jetzt noch
Schottland ich weiß aber ich habe mal
eben nachgeguckt da regnet es wenigstens
nicht ja Schottland ist ja eigentlich
ein total verregnetes Land auch
sicherlich verregnet heißt Deutschland
aber aktuell ist da besseres Wetter als
hier und was ja auch ganz klar ist vom
Loch Ness geht es natürlich noch weiter
wo es hingehen wird weiß ich noch nicht
aber vielleicht ja wieder in die Sonne
ja auf jeden Fall nice so wieder in die
Kälte ey ich habe einfach schon 15
Minuten muss jetzt noch hier durch
London
C42 okay Leute Security Check schauen
wir überstanden meine Kamera ist jetzt
gerade hinten im Rucksack weil ich mich
ein bisschen beeilen musste endlich
wieder am Flughafen ich habe es auch
sehr vermisst ich glaube ich brauche
meinen Reisepass heute den darf ich
nicht wieder vergessen so wie das letzte
Mal ist in Ordnung geflogen bin und ich
habe jetzt noch fünf Minuten mal gucken
ob ich in der Lounge hier noch einen
Kaffee bekomme ich habe heute nämlich
noch nichts gefrühstückt wir werden
sehen vielleicht wird's hell hier 26 ist
es glaube ich schaffe das noch ich war
hier auch noch ein Kaffee ein Cappuccino
schön kaputt
aus man kommt ja auch in diese Lounge
das wenn man Geld bezahlt und hier wäre
das jetzt 27,50 € gewesen das hätte ich
aber dann wirklich ein bisschen Abzocke
wenn ich ihn hier lang will so ganz
Frühstück aber schnell rein damit
danach bin ich hoffentlich richtig wach
[Musik]
okay Leute mittlerweile angekommen in
London hier haben wir es auch schon
Moment ach nee hier ist eine Stunde
früher hier ist gerade 7:44 Uhr in
Deutschland 8:44 Uhr und hier muss ich
jetzt umsteigen um dann von hier aus
nach Schottland zu fliegen wir fliegen
ja zu noch Nest diesem See falls Sie die
ersten Videos noch nicht geschaut habt
macht es auf jeden Fall ich habe jetzt
hier tatsächlich 5 Stunden umstiegszeit
also ich muss 5 Stunden totschlagen es
wird echt hart aber wir schauen jetzt
erstmal zu welchem Terminal ich muss ich
bin gerade in London heathrows glaube
ich der größte Flughafen in London und
dann geht's in 5 Stunden weiter nach
innen wenn es ich habe von dieser Stadt
noch nie gehört aber es ist die größte
Stadt dort oben neben noch West und da
ist ein Flughafen ist auch ziemlich
klein also die Stadt hat gerade mal
48000 Einwohner eine Sache die mir
gerade aufgefallen ist ich habe schon
mal geguckt bei booking nach Hotels das
ist einfach Arsch teuer da für zwei
Sterne Hotel eine Nacht 220 €. das hatte
ich auch lange nicht
hinter mir ist auf jeden Fall jetzt die
nächste Lounge und die testen wir jetzt
mal aus ey Scheiße Leute weil ich fünf
Stunden umsteigen muss wo das konnte ich
mir auch denken aber ich kann einfach
nur für drei Stunden die Launch deswegen
muss ich jetzt noch zwei Stunden hier
sitzen ganz kurz aber das Video enthält
freundlich Unterstützung von ipsource
ICE und was das ist und wir damit ganz
viel Spaß haben könnt erkläre bevor wir
weitermachen wollte ich euch ganz
schnell den Sponsor das heutigen Videos
vorstellen wenn ihr die letzten Videos
aufmerksam geschaut habt kennt ihr ihn
auch schon und zwar handelt es sich noch
mal um Yos Isaac eine super Plattform
mit der überall auf der Welt ganz
entspannt nebenbei ein bisschen Geld
verdienen könnt bzw an
forschungsumfragen teilnehmen könnt die
euch dann sozusagen Punkte bringen und
diese Punkte könnt ihr in ganz
verschiedene Gutscheine Amazon
Gutscheine Zalando Gutscheine und so
weiter und so fort umtauschen das cool
ist wenn ihr euch bei Apps + ICE ein
konnte zulegt dann müsst ihr erstmal ein
paar Interessen von euch ausfüllen was
trinkt ihr gerne für welche Autos
interessiert euch und so weiter und so
fort und bekommt dann wirklich nur
forschungsumfragen angezeigt die auf
eure eigenen Interessen abziehen gibt es
sowohl als App oder play Motor als auch
natürlich einfach über den Internet
Browser wie jetzt zum Beispiel hier an
meinem iMac da
erster Link in der Videobeschreibung
danke und wir machen jetzt weiter mit
dem Video und so sah die Lounge schon
von innen aus der erste Eindruck war
erstmal ganz gut auch wenn es wirklich
viel zu voll war auch das Essensangebot
war vielseitig und vielfältig nur die
Qualität des Essens war wirklich brotlos
also zumindest wenn sie vernünftige
Flughafenlounge sein soll aber die
Qualität das Essen zwar ungefähr auf
einem Level mit meiner damaligen
schulmenser nichtsdestotrotz konnte ich
mich noch einige Zeit ausruhen aber war
echt leider die schlechteste Lounge
schon gleich bis jetzt war okay Leute
übrigens eine Stunde Verspätung ein
bisschen ärgerlich ich bin jetzt einfach
schon fast sechs Stunden hier am
Flughafen also wirklich eine ganz schön
lange Zeit und natürlich aber das war
die schlechteste Lounge von der ich hier
weiß war echt dreckig das Essen war
eigentlich fast ungenießbar also ich
habe mich auch sehr gewundert aber was
willst du machen jetzt geht's los in
einer halben Stunde fliegen wir los und
ich muss jetzt zu Geld a 15 und dann bin
ich endlich irgendwann heute mal
angekommen nach ungefähr zehn Stunden
ich habe auch übrigens glaube ich das
hässlichste Shirt
vom ganzen Flughafen an aber so orange
ist doch eine gute Farbe oder deswegen
[Musik]
okay Leute geschafft
Inverness was geht ab bisschen kalt hier
aber sonst gute Luft das ist auch
wirklich stumpf das hier überhaupt ein
Flughafen ist stellt euch meine deutsche
Stadt vor mit 40.000 Einwohnern mit
Flughafen Immigration das mache ich
jetzt heute schon zum 8 mal gefühlt okay
überraschenderweise muss ich meinen
Reisepass jetzt noch nicht vorzeigen
glaube ich zumindest wir müssen jetzt
allerdings noch 10 km fahren bis zum
Zentrum von Inverness und dann sind wir
auch nicht bei lochness aber das mache
ich glaube ich eher erst morgen erstmal
Pulli anziehen
dann sehe ich auch nicht mal so hässlich
aus
eigentlich hätte ich gedacht hier gibt
es eine Zugverbindung das sah zumindest
so aus aber ich sehe hier kein Zug doch
hier musst du eigentlich nur zustation
sein schaut mal hier ich schau mal eben
nach also hier sieht irgendwie nicht
nach Zug aus eigentlich von der
Landschaft her eh nicht wie in
Deutschland ne ich frage mich eben genau
jetzt nehme ich mir jetzt ein Taxi oder
speichergeld ich glaube ich nehme ein
Taxi also Schottland ist wirklich Arsch
teuer aber scheiß drauf ich will ja was
sehen und jetzt nicht hier noch
eineinhalb Stunden deswegen fahren wir
mit Taxi ich hoffe ich wenigstens mit
Karte bezahlen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte schon sagen das Wetter ist
hier besser aber jetzt fängt es ja auch
an zu regnen erster Eindruck ist auf
jeden Fall ziemlich geil ich glaube ich
bin hier komplett in der Altstadt bin
jetzt mal aufs Hotel gespannt und das
hier neben mir ist auch direkt schon der
NAS River von der führt aber zum Lachen
ist das heißt ich muss eigentlich nur
geradeaus Rennen habe ich mein Ziel
erreicht aber das sind halt 15 Kilometer
und hier Mann was für mich okay hier
sind wahr
let's go ist ja ein schönes Haus okay
okay
12 habe ich mal gespannt alles auf jeden
Fall ein bisschen verwinkelt hier und
auch im älteren Stil aber gut ist ja
nicht schlimm machen wir mal eine kurze
roomtour ja schöner Fernseher tolles
Bett bequem fit oh ich hätte mir jetzt
einen Ausblick zum Schluss gewünscht
aber es ist komplett zu falschen Seite
na toll gleich raus es ist wirklich
super Scottish oder so wie man sich das
ich war Screenshot dann ich war nur mal
in Irland und in England aber da sieht
das eigentlich auch überall so aus nur
ich muss wirklich sagen dieses Zimmer
hat mich jetzt umgerechnet
20084 € gekostet
also in Deutschland würde ich für
Sonnenzimmer nicht mehr als 70 €
bezahlen ich weiß auch nicht warum ihr
Hotel zu teuer sind es gibt ja auch so
ein Ranking die teuersten Städte der
Welt da habe ich jetzt Inverness noch
nicht drin gefunden aber von den
Hotelpreisen her wäre es auf jeden Fall
Platz 1 definitiv ich bin jetzt seit 11
Stunden wach und ja eigentlich 11
Stunden unterwegs gewesen dass ich jetzt
endlich mal hier angekommen bin obwohl
es gar nicht so weit weg ist war nicht
so leicht hinzukommen ich rufe mich
erstmal ein bisschen aus und dann
erkunden wir mal in Venice wir haben
jetzt hier halt fünf in Deutschland
schon halb sechs und morgen früh geht's
dann direkt los zum lochness aber da
würde ich gerne ein bisschen mehr Zeit
mitbringen und deswegen möchte ich da
jetzt nicht so oft Krampf noch hinfahren
ich weiß auch noch gar nicht wie ich
dahin komme also wir sehen uns heute
okay ich habe mich kurz einmal frisch
gemacht jetzt richtig auch wieder gut
ups das war auch wieder so klar hier
gibt's natürlich nur Steckdosen mit
Adapter den habe ich vergessen ich habe
gar nicht dran gedacht aber zum Glück
ging das hier irgendwie auch ohne ja
jetzt lebt mein Handy wenigstens ich bin
auf jeden Fall halbt mir jetzt einmal
hier die Stadt anzugucken also in
Vanessa ich muss auf jeden Fall erstmal
fett was essen weil ich habe mega Hunger
und vielleicht noch eine Kleinigkeit zu
trinken schauen wir mal aber in erster
Linie darf man natürlich nicht vergessen
warum ich überhaupt hier bin und zwar
wegen Loch Ness wie schon gesagt ich
stehe morgen extra früh auf Werte mit
dem Bus denke ich dahin fahren da gibt's
doch irgendwie so ein Messi Center was
sie so aufgebaut haben extra für
Tourismus und dann schauen wir mal ob
ich das Monster finde ich habe mir auch
auf dem Hinweg hierhin so ein paar
Sachen angeguckt es ist ja nämlich so
dass dieser Mythos Nessi also eigentlich
ist ja ein Mythos weil das Dingen wollte
ja noch nie wirklich gesehen es gibt
zwar seit mehreren hundert Jahren immer
wieder Sichtung und dann natürlich auch
Beweisfotos die da aber komischerweise
total verschwommen aussehen oder
irgendwelche Videos wo sich irgend so
ein Ding durch wasserschlängel was mein
Toaster gefilmt hat aber das erste Mal
wurde Nessi wohl schon im Jahr 500 nach
Christus gesehen und jetzt seit 1934
meine ich was häufen sich wohl die
Sichtungen und natürlich auch durch die
Fotografie die dann irgendwann dazu kam
haben Zeitung das abgedruckt und dadurch
wurde das halt immer berühmter und
seitdem gibt es halt auch wirklich immer
mal wieder so Suchaktion und hier gibt's
so ein Brief es ist eine organisierte
Beobachtung des Loch Ness das ist
großartig sagte Vollzeit Nessi suche
hast die Feld haben der
Nachrichtenagentur dpa wenn ihr mehr
Augen auf das Wasser gerichtet sind
desto besser feldham sucht seit mehr als
30 Jahren direkt am See nach dem Monster
wo länger als jeder andere das heißt der
Typ ist einfach
Vollzeit der arbeitet nicht der Sucht
Vollzeit halt das Messi Ding warum auch
nicht ne keine Ahnung von der sich
finanziert aber das war nicht ganz
lustig und da gibt's halt noch so ein
paar andere total verrückte Leute die
teilweise natürlich auch mit
irgendwelchen Fake Bildern dann beweisen
wollen dass es Nessi gibt und ja die
Leben Halt und suchen seit mehreren
Jahrzehnten nach diesem Dingen und jetzt
kommt Alex ist ein Tag hier und findet
direkt wahrscheinlich oder ich bin da
echt mal gespannt was morgen auf mich
zukommt wollte ich noch irgendwas sagen
also hier auf dem Foto kann man es ganz
gut sehen so soll Nessi aussehen wie so
ein Dinosaurier außer Uhrzeit halt der
irgendwie überlebt hat und Nessi lebt in
den Tiefen von Loch Ness und kommt aber
manchmal auch raus irgendwie aber auch
super selten nur ich frag mich an dieser
Stelle auch ich als Kind zum Beispiel
habe das geliebt ich habe auch den Film
dazu geguckt kann ich euch empfehlen und
es war ein geiler Film aber warum lässt
man den Mythos Messi nicht einfach
Mythos sein und ganz viele Leute Träumen
anstatt immer wieder irgendwelche
Suchaktion mit High End technikgeräten
zu starten weil ich sag mal so der
Mensch ist ja mittlerweile auch schon
ziemlich weit fortgeschritten und wenn
es Nessi wirklich geben würde bin ich
mit ziemlich sicher hätten wir sie schon
gefunden eine ganz kurze kleine Chance
besteht aber bestimmt noch dass es nicht
so ist und ich der erste Mensch sein
wird der mit einer 4k Kamera das Ding
finden so und jetzt gehen wir mal ändern
okay
so sieht das aus eigentlich ziemlich süß
ne und wir Steppen jetzt aber da vorne
hin in die City ja das Wetter hier ist
auf jeden Fall sehr schottisch es
scheint die Sonne aber es regnet Leute
mal kurz Werbung in eigener Sache und
zwar wenn ihr das schneller erfahren
wollt wo ich so rumreise folgt mir auf
jeden Fall bei Instagram da mache ich
immer schön fleißig Stories würde mich
freuen Alex wie heiße ich da auch könnt
ihr mir auch gerne mal schreiben und so
freue mich ich gehe auf jeden Fall jetzt
erstmal Burger essen Burgerladen der ist
richtig gut bei Google und ich habe
irgendwie Hunger drauf und dann will ich
noch ein Pub gehen ja habe ich auf jeden
Fall direkt und da ist auch schon der
Burgerladen ey Leute ich habe so hunger
was ist das erste Tag
okay Leute ich habe jetzt auf jeden Fall
Platz gefunden gebt euch mal diesen
Ausblick hier einfach direkt schön auf
dem Fluss es war ziemlich groß hier aber
ich bin mal gespannt also auf jeden Fall
Smash Burger geworden
[Musik]
Burger ist nicht für jeden was ich
feiere die sehr und die haben einen sehr
gut umgesetzt hat ein bisschen
geschmeckt wie ein Big Bag in gut
deswegen kann ich euch den Laden
empfehlen Coyote Burger hier in
Inverness wenn ihr mal hier seid checkt
den doch einfach mal aus und wir gehen
jetzt hier mal noch ein bisschen durch
die Altstadt mal gucken was ich da so
finden werde ihr kennt ja
Pflichtprogramm ein Local Bier muss sein
und das werden wir auf jeden Fall jetzt
gleich noch schön genüsslich zum
Abschluss des Abends trinken da vorne
ist glaube ich die Haupt Einkaufsstraße
und hier sind überall dann so enge
Gassen ja also man muss dann irgendwo
hat es was ist jetzt auf jeden Fall
nicht so meine Patrick City wenn ich das
hier so sehe aber es ist schon irgendwo
schön hier gibt's auch das nächste Hotel
City rooms das kostet wahrscheinlich 420
€ die Nacht ich muss sagen was ich
wirklich sehr mag ist einfach irgendwo
lang zu gehen man weiß nicht was kommt
und ja freut sich schon auf irgendwas
z.B hier geht's jetzt die Treppen hoch
und das könnte sein dass da hinten
gleich eine coole Burg kommt weil die
habe ich schon so leicht gesehen ihr
sagt ja auch immer ich soll immer die
Videos ein bisschen länger machen
deswegen lass ich das jetzt einfach
alles drin vieles bei uns immer
rausgeschnitten aber falls euch das
gefällt lasst doch mal einen Däumchen
nach oben da times now hier wirklich
Nussbaum Beauty passiert Bully booked ja
und wie man jetzt hier sehen kann ah es
hat sich mehr oder weniger gelohnt also
ich sehe jetzt zwar noch nicht noch nass
aber irgendwo da hinten links müsste das
anfangen also ja ungefähr und wenn man
mal ganz leise ist hört man auch die
Möwen und so das ist einfach eine ruhige
schöne Kleinstadt wo die Welt noch in
Ordnung ist
[Musik]
aber probier mal eben
na gut manchmal ist es auch echt los
wenn ich so alleine dann ein Pub sitze
aber ja aber halt keinen Freund dabei
aber hier ist auf jeden Fall schon was
los guten Morgen Leute ich hoffe euch
geht's gut immer noch ich habe wirklich
wunderbar geschlafen in dem Bett habe
mich richtig erholt gestern war ja auch
ein anstrengender Tag ich glaube ich
habe 9 Stunden Schlaf bekommen das hatte
ich lange nicht auf reisemonopoli und
jetzt habe ich mir schon meine
Windbreaker Jacke angezogen entspannte
Jeans und ich würde sagen heute ist der
große Tag warum ich überhaupt hier bin
wir machen uns auf den Weg zu Loch Ness
ich habe Bock ich hoffe ihr auch und ja
schnell auschecken und dann geht's los
so ich sitze jetzt hier wieder auf einer
Bank und warte auf meinen Taxi im
Internet stand nämlich dass es hier oben
gibt aber das gab's nicht dann sollte
ich mir diese App hier runterladen
safecup die gibt's auch nicht die ist
nicht mehr verfügbar und jetzt muss ich
bei it Taxis anrufen und ich hoffe das
klappt zurück habe ich aber vor auf
jeden Fall mit dem Bus zu fahren schauen
wir mal ob das funktioniert wird wie es
mir vorstelle Taxi gestiegen und der
Taxifahrer war echt richtig cool er hat
mir super viel erklärt auch wenn es für
mich nicht immer einfacher zuzuhören
weil gerade der schottische Akzent und
wenn die Leute dann auch so schnell
sprechen ist nicht immer einfach
verständlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er wollte mir dann unbedingt noch diese
Büffel zeigen das ist wohl irgendwie so
ein Ding da coole Tiere habe ich nicht
ganz verstanden aber ich habe trotzdem
viel gelernt in kurzer Zeit und wir
steigen jetzt erstmal aus und day thank
you bye bye okay wir sind am See der
Taxifahrer hat mich freundlicherweise zu
einem wohl ziemlich guten Sport gemacht
hier ist jetzt gleich so eine Burg eine
alte muss ich noch mal gucken wie ich
dahin komme heute morgen hat auf jeden
Fall richtig die Sonne geschienen jetzt
hat sich wieder ein bisschen zugezogen
aber ja Ticket kaufen
[Musik]
also wenn ich ihn jetzt gelandet 14,50
€, nee sogar 18 Euro umgerechnet schauen
wir mal ob sich das wenigstens lohnen
wird gibt es aber noch eine Kleinigkeit
zu essen mit wunderbaren touristischen
Blick aufs Loch Ness ja also ist schon
auf jeden Fall ein sehr schöner See
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich liebe ja immer diese
touristischen mega Spots das habe ich
mir zwar ein bisschen anders vorgestellt
aber egal kann man ja auch mit rechnen
dass das hier so voll ist aber ich werde
lieber an irgend wo ich so irgendwie für
mich bin aber jetzt muss ich auch nutzen
wir gehen jetzt mal runter also ich gehe
auf jeden Fall erstmal runter zum Wasser
da vorne auf den Steg würde ich gerne
und wenn man ersten Überblick über die
Lage verschaffen ich muss aber leider
sagen auch wenn der Spot hier sehr sehr
schöne ist man sieht sich auch es ist
alles wirklich sehr sehr gesund hier die
Natur schön grün es ist halt
geisteskrank überlaufen ein bisschen ab
und für diese komische Burg da also ja
schön ist eine Burg gibt's auch bei mir
eine Heimatstadt sieht genauso aus habe
ich jetzt 18 € bezahlt und jetzt darf
ich nicht mal hier drauf gehen ja wow
also hier gehe ich jetzt aber mal runter
okay Leute wir haben es geschafft
noch nass
auch ganz schön kalt stop vier der Reise
erfolgreich gemeistert hinter mir ist
wirklich also muss man wirklich sagen
eine der schönsten sehen an dem ich hier
war und irgendwo in diesem See lebt ein
Monster was aber der Taxifahrer noch
nicht gesehen hat der schon seit 36
Jahren hier wohnt
[Musik]
bin überlegen ob ich auch so eine Boot
zu machen soll Alter was geht denn jetzt
hier auch vorbei an sich ja lohnt sich
das wir gehen jetzt auf jeden Fall
erstmal noch in Ruhe wirklich was für
eine Völkerwanderung oder
ja das ist die Burg für 18 Euro kann man
nicht meckern oder ist doch nichts los
hier jetzt mal an zurück und ja super
Leute ich werde mich jetzt auf jeden
Fall auf einen kleinen Wanderweg begeben
und einmal hier komplett rumwandern das
sind 5 km und von da aus geht es dann
irgendwann später wieder zurück aber das
muss ich jetzt antreten wird bestimmt
gar nicht mal so unanstrengend let's go
Leute der Taxifahrer hat mich ja
freundlicherweise freundlicherweise ich
hoffe dass das freundlicherweise war bis
da unten mit hingenommen und jetzt muss
ich den ganzen Weg wieder zurücklaufen
weil da unten auch nichts fährt kein Bus
und so aber von hier hat man jetzt auch
noch mal einen sehr sehr schönen
Ausblick auf noch nass ja der See ist
übrigens 24 Meilen lang also es ist
wirklich ja wenn man einmal rumrennen
möchte schon ganz schön langer Weg und
eine Sache die ich auch noch nicht
erwähnt habe und zwar okay natürlich ist
es noch ein Mythos gibt es Nessi oder
nicht aber seit 1933 steht das Monster
von Loch Ness unter Artenschutz das
heißt wenn es das gibt das nicht gejagt
oder gefangen werden es gibt wirklich
ein Gesetz von der Regierung wo das drin
steht also ist es vielleicht doch gar
nicht so unwahrscheinlich dass es
wirklich irgendwo hier drin existiert
wer weiß ich glaube dran ja es gibt auch
Leute die wohnen sogar direkt am Loch
Ness hier z.B eigentlich ganz nice und
ich frage mich gerade warum ich hier
oben mit den ganzen Touristen lang gehe
wenn da unten auch noch einen Weg ist
scheiße für die dies interessiert der
Taxifahrer hat mir auch erzählt dass es
hier erlaubt ist will zu kämpfen also
ihr könnt ihr überall Campen wo ihr halt
Bock drauf habt das ist auch ein großes
Ding hier vor allem hier auch am Loch
Ness und hier in dieser schönen
Landschaft zu Kenntnis glaube ich auch
echt geil ja also wenn man mal was
anderes sucht außer irgendwie Malle oder
so zum Urlaub machen shot dann ist halt
was ganz anderes ne ach und wenn man
schon mal hier sind ich bin ja total
Fußball begeistert hier spielt der erste
FC Loch Ness hier befinde ich mich jetzt
übrigens gerade in Roma von heißt das
glaube ich das ist so die anderen ganzen
Stadt hier und hier ist natürlich alles
voll mit Loch Nessi
Fanartikeln und Merch eigentlich muss
ich mir noch so ein T-Shirt hier
mitnehmen oder so sieht also Nessi aus
ja den habe ich heute noch nicht gesehen
das schaut gefällt mir besonders gut ich
glaube an dich ja okay und während ich
hier durch diese wirklich geile
Landschaft laufen dahinter mir irgendwie
Schafe gejagt werden oder zusammen
getrieben werden habe ich so auch noch
nie gesehen würde ich die vierte Folge
von reisemonopoly gerne erstmal beenden
vielleicht bin ich euch noch kurz ein wo
ist in der nächsten Folge hingeht weil
ich habe auf jeden Fall noch vor zwei
Folgen zu produzieren und ich werde
natürlich von hier aus jetzt auch direkt
wieder weiterreisen ansonsten vielen
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen ich hoffe auch dass
diese Folge jetzt endlich mal noch
deutlich länger geworden ist als die
letzten Folgen aber abonniert sehr sehr
gerne den Kanal lasst doch nach oben da
und wir sehen uns in paar Tagen wieder